[Music]
i filmed these clips while on a hiking
trip last week
i forgot to film an intro or even like a
short segment explaining where we are or
what we're doing
this is matt and renee two of my
favorite humans i've been lucky to call
friends for the past six or seven years
they're based in washington so we try to
see as much of each other as possible
every summer before the rain moves in
and i head south
but this year they're buying another van
for extended winter trips which i'm
personally really excited for
[Music]
you guys are such dogs
i'm just
doing snot
[Music]
this summer has been a strange one in
many ways amazing in other ways just
plain confusing
i've been living on the road full-time
for three years and five months now and
i'm starting to question what comes next
for the longest time my only focus has
been the road and beyond that i've
always envisioned a long stretch of
international travel and then returning
to the states to buy land and begin the
process of building a home with
everything that's been going on in the
world since march 2020 extended
international travel still feels a bit
up in the air
and choosing a state to live in and
buying land feels like a big scary
commitment it feels like settling down
and leaving the road
that's the scariest thing of all
honestly i'm not sure what i'm doing
[Music]
so this lookout
is closed
you can only get in there
only the rangers can get in there but
it looks so cool
i think it'd be awesome to live up in
one of these for a month
just like read and write
be so peaceful
so we're cooking up some dinner before
sun sets
and we just found out we have full lte
you literally work remotely up here and
a mirror there's a mirror wow this is
better than the van
what are you guys having for dinner um
ragu pasta you said it wasn't great it
was regular yeah
pasta and alfredo pasta they're both
vegetarian this one's vegan and this
one's vegetarian i wish it was like
perpetual fall in washington
if that were the case i would
100
no question
right
[Music]
[Laughter]
action
this beautiful rays
but it's also starting to get really
cold
just ate dinner and i'm gonna go set up
my tent
so that once the sun is gone i can just
dive right in and be warm
so pretty
[Music]
[Music]
the light's getting really really good
so
running down to set up my tent
and change into some warmer clothes
out of my hiking pants and stuff like
that and then i'm gonna run back up to
the fire tower lookout and shoot sunset
so here's home for the night just got
all set up
so pretty here
uh
[Music]
oh actually look at that cloud yeah
crazy
[Music]
this is what i admit when i said
they're going off to their tent and i'm
going off to mine
[Laughter]
would you look at that would you look at
that
just look at it
all right so i just hung up my food and
trash
we are in bear country here at mount
rainier national park we've got black
bears around
and
matt and renee are camped over there
and i am camped
down the trail quite a ways
and then i turn off to the right so a
little bit secluded
good morning
the wind is so loud outside
and there's frost on
the tent right now
i do not want to get out of my sleeping
bag but
time to go get the coffee from the bear
bearpole and
head out to go shoot sunrise
i feel like these next few scenes really
mirror what life has been like lately
stumbling around in the dark one step at
a time attempting to create while also
being in the moment
only to realize halfway through that
i've forgotten to turn my mic on which
is why i have music playing instead
like i said i don't know what i'm doing
i'm still learning how to film and what
to film how to stay grounded while
living on the road how to run a business
from the road how to stay happy and
healthy and all of the things
there aren't many road maps out there
explaining how to live as a full-time
nomad long term
especially these days when so many
things feel subject to change
and though i will be the first to say
it's a beautiful way to live it does
come at a cost some days that cost is
overwhelm other days it's a lack of
community lack of stability lack of
clean underwear and sometimes it's just
plain decision fatigue i try to remind
myself that it's okay to be in that
space it's okay to lean into all the
things i don't know and just learn as i
go
choosing the wrong path getting lost and
making mistakes have all been important
parts of my journey guideposts in a way
for me personally it's the challenging
moments that force me to grow the most
and ask myself the deeper questions like
how can i contribute during my time here
on this earth how do i define happiness
and
did i remember to turn the mic on this
time
[Music]
too bad my coffee cup is full of dirt i
actually dropped it in the dirt this
morning
and also because i like coffee and
and i'm sleepy
you guys are such dogs
so i'm all packed up and heading back up
to the lookout
then we're gonna head down the trail and
yeah
it was so cold this morning but it's
starting to get toasty right now this
down jacket's definitely coming off soon
spending time outdoors in nature has
been one of the few constants in my life
since moving on to the road going into
the mountains just it always feels like
going home
being out here just makes me happy and
so often it offers up perspective in
this case a reminder that it's okay to
not know what you're doing
it's okay to spend the day just putting
one foot in front of the other roaming
forested trails picking huckleberries
laughing with friends falling asleep
beneath the stars it's more than okay
it's great it's pretty amazing actually
and i can say with absolute confidence
that i have no idea what comes next
but i'm excited for it anyway thrown in
our bags time to get some food to get
some food
and
as i'm sure you might have guessed no i
did not film an outro for this video
either
but thanks for being here i'll see you
guys next time
i just see you creeping around the
corner